some of us might be looking forward to a
vacation on a beautiful island this
summer yes please but not all islands
are equal when it comes to emergency
medical care there is one in the
caribbean where if your life is in
danger medical help may not arrive even
if an ambulance shows up our lead
national correspondent that of course is
david begno traveled to an island off
puerto rico's main island and has more
on this story david good morning to you
good morning it is a beautiful island
when you book a vacation do you check to
see if there's an ambulance service that
will respond with trained medical
personnel and the equipment needed if
you have an emergency
most people probably don't
but that is the situation on coolabra
for the nearly 1800 year-round residents
and the tourists who helped to keep the
economy going
so we traveled by boat 17 miles from the
main island of puerto rico to kulebra
after we got word about recent drownings
on the island i want to warn you some of
the video you are about to see may be
disturbing
puerto rico's flamenco beach is
considered among the world's best
located on the island of culebra
tourists flock here between 500 and 700
000 visitors visit the island every year
and they come to this beach
attorney julian rivera aspinall
represents the family of manny ma of
boise idaho the 62 year old ma drowned
while snorkeling off this beach last
december his wife found them floating
out in the ocean he was
eventually pronounced dead
and unfortunately there wasn't any way
of being able to save his life here at
the beach
there's been a grave danger here that
the locals know all too well
but the visitors almost never do
if your life is in danger
help is almost non-existent
when we were there there was not a
single lifeguard on the beach
we did see this man using a whistle to
keep people from going too far out into
the surf he says he's a volunteer not
paid not trained he just wants to help
i'm thinking that i'm coming to this
beautiful beach and i'm gonna see a
lifeguard or two here i was surprised to
see no lifeguards while we were there we
met maria linden and julian rivera from
new york city and they asked what we
were working on
so i explained to them that not only did
flamenco beach not have lifeguards
there was no one employed as a certified
paramedic on the island
there's not even a working ambulance
stocked with the supplies needed to save
your life before the two of you came
here to visit culebra did you think for
a moment whether or not there was a
working ambulance no
she's just telling me this time i'm
stunned right now
[Applause]
we wanted to speak with cool labor's
mayor el deberto romero yvette to find
out what's happening here just so i
understand you clearly you don't have an
ambulance staffed 24 hours a day here in
kulebra correct correct
that's scary see
because your
i mean your number one industry here is
tourism see
he's been the mayor here in culebra for
a little bit more than a year and he
says he's trying to change things but
the high cost of living on the island
and a lack of certified personnel is
making it extremely difficult to employ
qualified medical professionals i need
paramedics i need a doctor and a
technical
emergency emergency
i need that people come to work in
colebra while the mayor waits on the
right people back on flamenco beach he
is taking steps to make the beach safer
installing bilingual signs red flags and
a lifeguard stand what do you think
about that well that's progress that's
great
again i am very happy that the island of
culebra is eventually taking steps so
that these types of accidents don't
happen again my client's accident was
not the only accident that has occurred
here back in february of this year
sharoja paramanathan her husband theeva
and their kids traveled from toronto to
flamenco beach and culebra for vacation
that is when the unthinkable happened
onlookers called 9-1-1 as good
samaritans administered cpr to the
40-year-old father of three who they
dragged out of the water witnesses say
it took at least 30 minutes for an
ambulance just to show up they're not
emergency officials they're just two
drivers basically that's what they are
so this is essentially like a taxi yep
it's basically a taxi that says
ambulance
wow
do you feel like they did anything to
try and save your husband's life no it
was just easy
easy i know it's it's another another
person for them
it was it was just easy
sorry that's all you could do
sharogia's husband died
tomorrow you are going to hear more from
her and you're going to meet two of the
good samaritans who tried to save her
husband's life you will also hear
directly from one of the ambulance
drivers who arrived on the scene that
day
and what happened when he got there what
did he actually do
we'll tell you
this is so upsetting david because i
think when you go on vacation just
you almost let your guard down you
certainly don't think that you're going
to die on vacation and certainly not
snorkeling
you think if it does somebody will be
there to help you take it for granted
you're going to call for help and they
come right that's what's going up in the
states wait until you hear tomorrow when
i say to the guy the paramedic yeah when
the states were used to this wait until
you see his reaction but i want you to
know that the good people of nate you
asked how many people lived there
roughly 1800 permanently
they've been dealing with this for years
they've been begging
begging the island's government to fix
this yeah but the tourists that go there
don't know that right
so that's what's so frightening but the
locals will tell you why does it take
tourists to fix what we've been ranting
about for years tourists dying bingo
right and why is the tourism important
because it's the number one the
monastery there yeah i find it
remarkable that the mayor while you're
saying those asking those questions he's
agreeing yes we don't have paramedics
look i think the mayor wants to get it
fixed he just doesn't have the money and
he just can't get the people well i like
him being very plain about it yes you're
right as opposed to trying to explain
well he's not running away from it yeah
yeah all right david thank you we'll see
you tomorrow part two yes yes looking
forward to that